the opening day was what they called
Black Sunday and that's because so many
things didn't work yes I was there on
opening day I was in charge of all the
behind the scene catering for all the
stars and it was an absolute total
disaster and the problem was somebody
was counterfeiting tickets for the
opening so where they expected about 20
or 25,000 ended up with 35,000 people
and park just couldn't handle it in
those days the chaos of that day was
first of all we all did a lot of things
in those days and I got a call to get
down to the Mark Twain because it was
sinking and it was actually the deck was
underwater because there were too many
guests on the boat it was so hot it was
about a hundred degrees that day in
Anaheim and ladies came in those days
they came all dressed up their high
heels would sink into the asphalt
because it was so fresh and then we had
a gas leak Infanta spin so we had a
close fantasy land
few weeks before the opening there was a
major meeting and it was a plumbing
strike so I'll never forget this and I
happen to be in the meeting so that the
contractor was telling Walt Walt there's
just not enough hours in the day to do
to finish the restrooms and to finish
all the drinking pounders and this is
classic Walt and I'm gonna say it
because it was Walt Disney he said well
he said you know they can drink Coke and
Pepsi but they can't pee in the streets
finished the restrooms well then he was
accused of forcing people to buy
coca-cola and PepsiCo because there
weren't enough drinking fountains so we
were spending all of our time trying to
repair those images of the park and show
people what it really was like they
asked him when Disneyland would be
completed meaning all those things that
weren't working and he said Disneyland
will never be completed as long as
there's imagination left in the world
I was going to the University of
Southern California actually getting my
master degree I was planning on being a
coach and I need a temporary job the
summer so I started out an orientation
training there I was at the right place
at the right time got to know a
wonderful man by the name of Walt Disney
loved the vision that he had for
Disneyland and by the end of the summer
I decided to stay with it and make it a
permanent position and it lasted for
wonderful 44 years well I started at
Disneyland month before Disneyland open
and they were looking for someone to put
out a tabloid newspaper 1890 style on
Main Street and they hired me I was
about to be the editor of the daily
Bruin at UCLA two weeks after I went to
work I had to present the concept to the
Walt Disney and I was 21 years old and
had never worked professionally and I
was scared as hell
when Disneyland was announced okay in
1954 maybe 53 he said look we're gonna
charge to get in and the top execs at
that time says well nobody pays to get
into amusement park and he said both
first of all it's not going to meet
amusement park it's gonna be Disney
later and all the people in the
amusement industry thought he was crazy
you know they had multiple entrances and
he had one and he landscaped his and
kept the bathrooms clean and all of
those things that the public has
respected over the years and all the
people traditionally in the music
industry said he's nuts telling to save
his money
whatever we did yesterday he wasn't
interested in it anymore he just wanted
to know where we were going and what we
could contribute to that journey that he
was on and it was a wonderful way of
working Haley Graham cut came to the
part the Evangelist and we went down
Main Street got on the Jungle Cruise
this is 1964 Billy said well would have
what a fantastic world would a marvelous
world of fantasy and Walt said Billy
look around you all the people all
nationalities all colors all languages
all smiling all having fun together
Billy this is the real world the
fantasies outside I always say that the
most important attraction that we did in
the parks it's a small world this song
that Bob and Dick Sherman wrote there's
just one moon and one Golden Sun and a
smile means friendship to everyone think
about the fact that if we could get
everyone in the world to act that way
toward everybody else wouldn't it be a
great place and I don't think that's a
Pollyannish thing I think that's an
important lesson for young people to get
while they're having fun and after all
we're in the fun business that's first